Hi, I'm Erik Voss, and finally we have a
Star Wars Last Jedi trailer! Nothing in
this world can revert me back to a
widdle boy like Star Wars can. Not even
director Rian Johnson's initial warnings
to avoid watching the trailer could keep
me away. Clean? I don't wanna be clean!
By the way, he totally changed his mind
and give us the all-clear, so we good. There are a ton of new details from this
trailer, many of them super missable, and
I don't think everything is what it
seems to be here. So I'm gonna break it
all down, and if any of my speculation
and guesswork ends up being accurate -
possible spoilers ahead. Let's get started.
'When I found you... I saw... raw, untamed power!"
Okay, so with John Williams'
classic orchestral harp, we open on Kylo
Ren overseeing First Order construction.
Now if you look closely in that hangar,
you can see some original Empire AT-AT
walkers. That gives us a sense of scale
of this place. It is massive. Now I think
there's a very good chance this place is
The Supremacy - the new mega class star
destroyer and flagship of Supreme Leader
Snoke. It's wingspan is 60 kilometers.
Just for reference, The Inflictor, the
massive Star Destroyer that we saw
crash-landed on Jakku in The Force
Awakens was only 1.6 kilometers long.
So The Supremacy is the largest Star
Destroyer in any Star Wars movie. We
actually get a different look at it
later on. We also hear the voice of Snoke,
played by Andy Serkis. "When I found you, I saw raw, untamed power!"
Now despite Rian Johnson's initial
concerns, it seems like this trailer was
edited in such a way to misdirect us, and I
think that's what could be happening
here. Now it seems like Snoke is talking
to Kylo here, but it's also possible he's
talking to Rey. In The Force Awakens
novelization, when Rey battled with Kylo
and considered killing him off, Snoke reached
out to her and tried to recruit her. So,
raw, untamed power definitely seems to
describe Rey in that moment. Okay next up
we get these awesome shots from this
battle on Crait with new First Order
walkers advancing. Once again, they used
an original empire AT-AT for scale here.
Notice how much larger these new walkers
look by comparison. It was actually said
that the First Order would be using
these now smaller, old models as Scouts.
These new walkers were actually
nicknamed gorilla walkers and now we see
why - their front legs are fortified and
curled inward, resembling how a gorilla
walks on its knuckles. Also, these new
added shin card shields look like
they're there to cut any toe cables that
would be used to trip them up, showing
that they have learned from the Empire's
past mistakes in the Battle of Hoth. And
I love this detail of the red clumps of
dirt being kicked up here, it just makes
this battle feel more grounded and
authentic, like we're seeing tanks move
dirt as they shove through. The planet
of Crait is covered with white salt atop
red soil. We actually saw those
resistance fighters in the teaser
dragging up that dirt as well. And yeah,
that is Kylo Ren's upsilon class command
shuttle from The Force Awakens leading
the charge up there. And before I move on,
there's this overhead shot of Kylo
leading these First Order troops. Based
on the red streaks and the lava rock
there, this could be Crait, or that cavern
with red crystals that we end up seeing
later in the trailer. And it could just
be a coincidence, but the framing of this
shot reminded me of Anakin leading the
way into the Jedi Temple in Revenge of
the Sith.
Of course Kylo's connection to his
grandfather is definitely a key motivator
to his character, so it's possible this
was intentional. Anyway, let's move on.
"And beyond that... something truly special."
Okay, some interesting shots here.
First there's this shot of Kylo in his
helmet picking up his lightsaber in this
red room. Now it's kind of hard to tell, but
there are red elite Praetorian guards in
the background. They're kind of doing
that Tobias Funke camouflage move. Now,
these guys are similar to the red
imperial guards that accompany the
Emperor, but these Praetorian guards do
Snoke's bidding. There are eight of them
in total and they're supposed to be more
active, badass melee fighters. Actually,
behind-the-scenes footage showed Adam
Driver sparring with stunt guys, and I
think there's a good chance we'll see
Kylo having to fight these Praetorian
guards, maybe as a form of punishment
from Snoke for his failures in The Force
Awakens. But then when the trailer moves
onto this vibrant blue shot of Rey, I
love the color contrast this creates.
When you reverse the order of these
frames, it's like Rey and Kylo are back
in a duel, with Rey's blue lightsaber
against Kylo's red lightsaber. This red
vs. blue contrast is a common motif seen
in The Force Awakens, Luke and Vader in
Empire, Obi-wan and Vader in A New Hope,
and of course, Pokemon. Let's move on.
"Something... inside me has always been there. But now it's awake. And I need help."
Okay, so this section brings us back to
Luke's island on Ahch-To, the moment after the
ending of The Force Awakens. Now a few
subtle details I liked here: look closely
at Luke's cybernetic hand. It still has
the blast damage from when he was shot
in the hand on Jabba's barge in
Return of the Jedi. Also listen to the
music in this section. This is a modified
version of the Imperial March. Actually
several of John Williams' Star Wars
themes are mixed in here, and I'll point
out others as they come along. Now Rey's
voice over in this section is also
interesting. "Something inside me has always been there. But now it's awake." Now Rey is probably
referring to that force vision she
experienced in the preceding film,
fittingly titled The Force Awakens. So,
I'm expecting The Last Jedi to
revisit the imagery of that vision and
give new meaning to it. But I have more on
that later. Then in this shot, Rey hikes
to this ancient, rotting stump. Now in the
past we've speculated that Luke could be
living inside an old hollowed-out
Force Tree, perhaps the literal roots of
the first Jedi Temple. We also get some
more shots of Rey's lightsaber training,
including this badass stop, inches away
from the boulder. This reminds me of that
moment in The Matrix when Neo hit a
breakthrough, stopping his fist inches
away from Orpheus's face. You see, this is
what it looks like when a raw trainee
gains control. That's why I've never
actually hit anyone - total control. Don't
hit me!  Moving on.
"I've seen this raw strength only once
before. It didn't scare me enough then. It does now."
This new section shifts focus from Rey's
training to Luke's fear of what that
training could lead to. The intensity of
her focus cracks the ground she's
sitting on, leading to Luke saying this"
"I've seen this raw strength only once before. It didn't scare me enough then. It does now." So Luke is
referring to his past tutelage of Ben
Solo, Kylo Ren, who turned on him and
burned down his attempt to restart the
Jedi Order. We actually see more of that
memory here, with Luke actually being
there for that attack, crawling out of
the rubble. This fire could actually be
what burned away the synthetic skin from
Luke's cybernetic hand. And I think that
the reason Luke was in this fire was to
retrieve those ancient books that we saw
in the teaser, which remember looked a
little burned and smoke damaged. I talked
about how those could be the old
journals of the Wills, the spiritual
texts describing the old ways of the
force. I also like how Luke's fear in
this moment echoes the warning from Yoda
in Empire Strikes Back.
"I'm not afraid. You will be." It wasn't
just Vader and the emperor that Yoda was
wary of, it was the fear that your
student could one day use the skills you
give them to do others harm. Now before I
move on check out that circular symbol
on the ground behind Luke. It's not
totally clear what this is, but to me on
the left side of that circle, looks like
it could be a tree. Actually looking on
the right side, maybe there are two trees
there, one with a darker trunk and
lighter branches, and the other with a
lighter trunk and darker branches. This
is kind of like the circular yin and
yang symbol, but in this case
representing the dual sides of the Force.
If this Force Tree stump is indeed the
site of the first Jedi Temple, maybe this
symbol is a marker left behind to
indicate the location,s spiritual
significance. Let me know what you think.
Let's move on.
"Let the past die."
"Kill it...
If you have to."
"That's the only way to become what
you were meant to be."
This section of the trailer shifts to
Kylo, with the music in the section being
Williams's Kylo Theme from The Force
Awakens.
He smashes his helmet, leaving it in the
shattered pieces that we saw in the
teaser. Now, it's significant to see him
do this. That helmet was Kylo's link to
his grandfather. He built it and wore it
to more closely resemble Vader. Perhaps
he's smashing it now after learning the
truth about Vader - that in the end he
went soft and destroyed the Emperor. I'm
thinking this could be something Snoke
told Kylo in order to manipulate him
into further distancing himself from his
family ties. Listen to Kylo's voice over
here:
"Let the past die. Kill it if you have to. It's the only way to become what you were meant to be."
He targets his mother, Leia, on the bridge, and he clearly doubts that killing the past is something that will
actually help him. We know from The Force
Awakens novelization that murdering his
father Han Solo didn't necessarily give
him the increased strength that he hoped
it would. So maybe that doubt will
prevent him from doing the same to his
mother. And notice Kylo's dark, band-aid
sealant on his face scar. I suppose that
means his wounds from The Force Awakens are
still fresh, and that maybe this space
battle might be happening early in the
film. But let's zoom and enhance on this
space battle. Kylo's fighter is a TIE
silencer, and the way he pilots it
reminds me a lot of Anakin's piloting in
the opening of Revenge of the Sith. Now
in this battle it looks like the
First Order dreadnoughts are attacking the
resistance fleet, but if you look closely
these blasts aren't getting through the
dome shield that surrounds the ships. On
the right is an escort frigate which
looks like the Rebel Nebulon B from
Empire, and Leia looks like she's on a
Mon Calamari flagship called the Raddus.
Now the Raddus was named after Admiral
Raddus, the Mon Calamari who led the
rebel fleet in the Battle of Scarif to
retrieve the Death Star plans which we
saw in Rogue One, and if you look really
closely in the background, this massive
Star Destroyer looks like it actually
has a wing on the left side as well. And
I'm pretty sure this is The Supremacy
that I mentioned earlier. Meanwhile on
this bridge behind Leia are a few cameos.
There are these Mon Calamari flight
officers, many of whom appeared in The
Force Awakens, and some of you suggested
that this resistance officer looks like
Gareth Edwards, director of Rogue One. Now,
Edwards is supposed to get a cameo in
Episode 8 to return the favor of him
putting Last Jedi director Rian Johnson
in Rogue One.
Remember, he was a Death Star operator.
Alright, let's move on.
"We are spark... that'll light the fire... that'll burn the First Order down."
Okay, this section moves on to these
supporting characters: Poe Dameron, Finn,
Captain Phasma, and Chewie. Chewie appears
to have taken the wheel of the Falcon in
this movie. Here we see the Falcon evading TIE fighters in this interesting
cavern lined with red crystals. I'm thinking
this could be somewhere on Crait,
with those crystals being the same color
as the soil, or it could be a whole new
planet, we'll see. Joining Chewie in the
cockpit is this little cash grab by Disney,
because every major property has to
have some Baby Groot or BB-8 to add an
extra billion to the box office. Like, I
don't care, I love this thing. This is a
porg. They're the winged creatures native
to Ahch-To. Filmmakers actually got the
idea for them after seeing puffins, which
are cute goofy, little birds that hop
around the island of Skellig Michael,
where the Ahch-To scenes were shot.
These porgs were created with a mix of
CGI and puppetry, and notice how they
gave them these sharp little teeth. So, I'm
sure we'll see them adorably bite
someone. Next, we see more of what looks
like a resistance retreat. I think Poe and
the others are inside Mon Calamari
escape pods.
But notice Poe's tone here. "We are the spark that'll light the fire that'll burn the First Order down." Now, judging
by his expression, it seems like the
resistance might have just suffered some
big setback, so I'm thinking this is part
of that First Order assault that we saw
in the resistance hangar in the teaser.
Also, notice this huge blast that takes
out an entire resistance cruiser. Now if
you pause at the right moment, you see the
source of that blast. Again, that is The
Supremacy. It is massive and powerful
enough to take out an entire large ship
in one go. Now there's another quick
cameo behind Poe here - this woman is
Lieutenant Connix, you may remember her
from The Force Awakens. She's played by
Billie Lourd, Carrie Fisher's real-life
daughter. I was also interested in this
shot of Poe's x-wing as it takes off.
Looks like he strapped on an additional
booster to the back, leaving this exhaust
trail. We also get this awesome collision
between Finn and Captain Phasma. Notice
how Finn is dressed as a First Order
officer, we know he's going on an
undercover mission with resistance
engineer Rose to infiltrate the
First Order ranks. But I'm guessing that
one of those First Order officers will
recognize him and blow his cover. Someone
with a personal grudge after getting
left behind in a trash compactor on
Starkiller base. Captain Phasma redeeming
her literal throwaway role in The Force
Awakens - the weapon she's using looks
like a force pike, which were carried by
the Emperor's Red Guard, but this is
actually a new weapon from Phasma's
home world which will be described in her
book. Meanwhile, Finn is using that
First Order Z6 riot control baton, which
you may remember FN-2199 using
it against him in The Force Awakens.
Yes, it does appear
to fold out differently here, but maybe
those just an alternate option that
9s didn't use before. Anyway I just
love the look of this shot, with the
flames of the chaos, behind them and
Finn's face all reflecting off Phasma's
armor. I actually think this location
looks a lot like the possible Supremacy
interior that we saw before, so maybe,
like all giant enemy ships in star wars
movies, The Supremacy isn't long for this
galaxy. Let's move on.
"This is not going to go...
the way you think. Fulfill your destiny."
Okay, here we see this shot of Luke
knocked down in the rain, which is a
little similar to the imagery in Rey's
force vision, with Kylo and the Knights
of Ren. So this may be part of a memory
where he's talking to Kylo, warning him
that his turn to the dark side won't go
the way he thinks.
Also on Crait there are these crystal fox
creatures, running into the resistance
base probably retreating from those
gorilla walkers. Alright, screw the porgs, I
want one of these badasses. The look of
their ears looks like it could be
inspired by the ancient Egyptian Ibizan hounds. And then there's this shot
of Rey diving under the water, and notice
this huge skull. Now it could be whatever
killed that thing is a sea creature Rey
will now have to face. It's kind of a
Star Wars tradition for every movie to
include some over-the-top alien creature,
so I'm just excited to see what The Last
Jedi brings. And after more shots of this
awesome battle on Crait, we get the most
interesting shot of this trailer: a
close-up of Supreme Leader Snoke. Oh, man.
This render looks fantastic - his wrinkled
skin and misshapen head just look super
lifelike! But a big reason for that I
think is notice how his lower face is
covered. As we saw with the CGI for
Tarkin in Rogue One, animating the
movement of the lips and the jaw in an
authentic way is really difficult for
even the best artists to pull off. So you
know, just show Snoke in super-tight,
extreme close-ups from the nose up and
you'll be as golden as Snoke's robes.
Which... yeah.
They're gold. What's the deal with that?
Now Snoke appears to be torturing Rey
here, suspending her body and causing her
to shake violently. And notice what he says: "Fulfill your destiny!"
This is exactly what Emperor Palpatine
said to Luke before torturing him with
sith lightning in Return of the Jedi.
"Fulfill your destiny!" I think the takeaway
here is that Rey, after being rejected by
Luke, will seek to continue her training
and learn the truth about her origin, even if
it means turning to the dark side. When
really, Snoke would only want to use her
for her raw, untamed power. Let's move on
to this final section.
"I need someone... to show me my place in all this."
Okay, as I mentioned before, this trailer
has clearly been edited to misdirect us.
I think this final exchange is another
example of it. While I do think it's
possible that Rey reaches out to the
dark side in search of answers and
training, I don't think that's what's
happening here.
I just don't think these shots of Rey are
from the same scene. There's three pieces
of evidence that I noticed: first, the
lighting and color. Yes, both kylo and Rey
have the same fiery color tone on their
faces, but the lighting is different.
Rey looks like she's much closer to the
light source casting a harsher shadow on
the right side of her face.
Meanwhile the light on Kylo's face is
more evenly spread, suggesting that the
light source is further away. Secondly,
look at the background. Rey's location
appears to be relatively stable, while
Kylo is surrounded by smoke and embers.
Wherever he is, it's currently on fire. I
actually think the shot of Rey is taken
from the campfire scene that we saw in
the behind the scenes footage, and her
saying I need someone to show me my
place in all this is her last ditch plea
to Luke to train her. And then finally,
listen to her audio again. "--to show me
my place, in all this." To me, that echo doesn't sound
natural, almost like it was added with an
audio filter in post-production to make
it sound like Rey was in an interior
location, further trying to pull off this
illusion that she and Kylo are facing
each other. I don't know, this just
reminds me a lot of the way that Rogue
One trailer ended, remember when they
made it look like Jyn Erso had gone to
the dark side. "What will you become?" You
can't always trust Star Wars trailers,
people. Like this could all be left on
the cutting room floor by December. Which
do you think is more likely in The Last
Jedi, Rey turning to the dark side or Kylo
coming back to the light? And which
supporting character do you think will
steal this movie? Captain Phasma, the porg,
Snoke, or maybe one of the new characters
we didn't see in this trailer, like Rose,
or Vice Admiral Holdo, or Benicio Del
Toro's character. Comment down below ,and
tweet your thoughts to me @eavoss or
follow new rockstars on Twitter for
updates under videos. Now, this video is
brought to you by our good friends at
Loot Crate. Loot Crate is a monthly
subscription box service for epic geek
and gamer items and pop culture gear. For
less than $20 a month you get six to
eight items that include licensed gear,
apparel, collectibles, unique
one-of-a-kind items and more. Loot Crate
has supported youtubers since the
company's shipped its first crates. By
supporting Loot Crate, you support our
channel. Sign up at lootcrate.com/rockstars then enter the code rockstars
to save 10% on any new subscription, or
click on the link in the description.
September's theme was robotics, so we can
give you an idea of
what to expect. The October Loot Crate
theme is mythical, and it contains cool
items from Stranger Things, Marvel, Buffy
and Ghostbusters. You have until the 19th
at 9 p.m. Pacific to subscribe and
receive that month's crate, and when the
cut-off happens, that's it, it's over. So
we'll get on this! Like and share this
video and subscribe to new rockstars
for all our deep dives and analyses of
Star Wars stuff, and if you really want
to support this channel you can
contribute to us on patreon. Big thanks
to all of our current donors, especially
Kelly Hopper. Thanks for watching, bye.